[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
defense attorneys present their opening
statement in the penalty phase for the
parkland school shooter i'm confident
that once you hear nicholas's story
that you will know in your heart
that a vote for life is the right vote
and the latest in the search for kylie
rodney we have located a decedent inside
the vehicle
we believe
it is our missing person dive team
discovers a vehicle and a body in the
search for the missing 16 year old plus
i would um respectfully yield my
case to mr marchese excellent and um i
that's a wise decision a florida man
accused of attempted murder and
kidnapping will no longer represent
himself and later an ohio man stands
trial for the murder of his wife then it
was starting to sink in this
like what i would start what i was
seeing my second thought was who would
put a life-sized doll in the middle of
the woods that just didn't make sense to
me hear from the woman who found the
body of emily noble law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross in today for brian
buckmeyer we begin with the parkland
school shooters defense team finally
presenting its opening statement more
than one month after the penalty phase
of the trial began
in february 2018 a then 19 year old
gunman nicholas cruz opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
broward county florida 17 people 14
students and three teachers were killed
and 17 more injured in october of last
year cruz pleaded guilty to all charges
so it's now up to a broward county jury
to determine whether he receives life in
prison or is sentenced to death after
weeks of jury selection the penalty
phase began on july 18 when the
prosecution presented its opening
statement the defense opted to postpone
its opening until the prosecution
wrapped its case on monday the defense
did present its opening statement
largely pointed the finger at the
defendant's biological mother brenda
woodard
what do we know about brenda's pregnancy
we know that it was very stressful and
chaotic
the majority of her pregnancy she was
homeless and living on the streets
nicholas
cruz's prenatal vitamins
consisted
of cold 45
cisco bombing
crack cocaine
and cigarette
and because nicholas was bombarded with
all of those things
he was poisoned in the womb and because
of that his brain
was irretrievably broken
through no fault of him
for its first witness the defense called
women who knew cruz's biological mother
she described cruz's mother as a
prostitute who used drugs heavily during
her pregnancy
i asked her i said brenda
are you drug sick here take some of mine
here take this piece of crack is exactly
what i said to her and she said no and
ain't drugs i'm pregnant and i thought
oh my god
and then that's when we kind of got into
a little bit of a
it's my life and i'll do what i want to
and i was trying to tell her you know
bernie can't do this you're pregnant
babies
it's hard on him
she didn't care at that point
okay so even after she told you that she
was pregnant did you see her continue to
absolutely
alcohol absolutely drugs alcohol weed
cigarettes
anything she could get her hands on she
was just like me that was our daily
routine that's how we lived our life
cruz's half-sister took the stand monday
afternoon testifying that she saw her
mother smoking while pregnant with cruz
she then described how her mother
influenced her life
how did honey brenda as a mother affect
your life she just
introduced me to a life
that
no no child should ever be introduced to
and
you know
she has no regards
you know
for my life or
his life
joining us now is co-host terry often
and criminal defense attorney florina
altschiller maureen let me start with
you defense waited to give their opening
statement until it's presented the case
directly was that effective do you think
i think that was not effective
personally i would never wave my opening
until after the prosecution had an
opportunity to present all of their
evidence and here's why
for weeks the jury got to hear the
horrific details of the shooting without
anything else in their mind from the
defense and now that their minds are
already poisoned thinking like the
prosecutor this is the first time they
hear
anything that's resembling sympathy
toward the defendant i like to get ahead
of it i like to put that out there up
front and let the jury think about those
sympathetic factors before the
prosecution puts on their evidence
rather than after
terry austin the defense lawyers say
they're going to show the jury that cruz
had a very difficult troubled childhood
what's the impact you think on the jury
in terms of the decision they have to
make life or death
you know what brian that could have a
very large impact it's quite possible
that at least one of those jurors is
going to have some doubt and they might
not vote for the death penalty now
granted this is a very heinous crime and
if any case calls for the death penalty
it would be this case but listening to
the former friend listening to
the sister of the defendant frankly
danielle woodard you can see that he's
had a horrible life both before he was
born and after he was born what he was
subjected to so one of those jurors
might be affected by that and might just
say listen i can't vote for the death
penalty all right terry and lorena thank
you very much stay there we'll get back
to you shortly still ahead on law and
crime daily jury selection is underway
in the trial of florida versus trevor
summers
but first the disappearance of kylie
right investigators say a body
discovered over the weekend likely
belongs to the missing 16 year old
[Music]
welcome back a sad end to a search for a
missing teenager in northern california
divers found kylie rodney's suv and what
they believe to be her body in her
reservoir over the weekend long crimes
anjanet levy is here with the details of
the recovery anjanet
brian kylie rodney had been missing
since august 6th she had attended a
party at the prosser family campground
in truckee california with about 200
other teenagers it was actually a
graduation party and there was a frantic
search for kylie after she had texted
her mother that she'd be home within 45
minutes but was never heard from again
her phone last pinged around the prosser
lake a sheriff's team had searched the
area previously and hadn't found
anything but over the weekend a
volunteer group with adventures with
purpose found rodney's suv upside down
in the same area the nevada county
sheriff said she believes it is kylie's
body that was in the vehicle but the
coroner will make a positive
identification shannon moon says the
group asked law enforcement to assist in
the search of the lake
we're very fortunate that we had the
assistance of a volunteer group the
adventures with purpose that came out
with some very specific expertise and
were able to to help us in in locating
the vehicle that we had been searching
for
for several weeks
now adventures with purpose is led by a
man named doug bishop and he actually
talked about the discovery on the
group's facebook or the youtube channel
we began our search for kylie
at prosser creek reservoir on august
21st
at 10 40 a.m
we placed two sonar boats in the water
by 11 15 am
nick detected an object underwater using
cutting edge garmin sonar technology
i was able to then confirm that it was
in fact a vehicle in roughly 14 feet of
water
and only 55 feet offshore
now there have been a lot of questions
asked about why the sheriff's office
wasn't able to find the vehicle before
adventures with purpose you heard they
were in the water for less than an hour
when they found the suv and the
sheriff's office had used similar
technology to that used by the volunteer
group the placer county sheriff says
that they'll be talking with the group
and reviewing their training to
determine how on earth that could have
happened and an autopsy on that body
found in kylie's vehicle believed to be
hers will be conducted on tuesday brian
what a story internet terry the
volunteer agency able to find the car so
quickly when other agencies were
unsuccessful for weeks could this lead
to some kind of claim of negligence
i think it absolutely could there is a
cause of action called negligent
infliction of emotional distress and all
you have to do is demonstrate that one
party owes a duty to another party there
was a breach of that duty and that
breach caused damages and in this case
there's no question that the authorities
did not find the car and the body before
these individuals and this voluntary
group did and
there could have been negligence here if
they had the same equipment why didn't
they have the same training so i do
think that you could have distress from
not knowing where your daughter is and
you could bring a claim so we'll see
what happens but it's a sad situation no
doubt no doubt florina as the
investigation continues now with the
body and the vehicle submerged for so
long will it make it difficult to
extract dna or other evidence
it will but really i don't think dna
will be determinative in this case even
if found all dna would say is that that
person at some point was in the vehicle
what i think will be conclusive is the
autopsy the autopsy will determine the
mode manner and cause of death whether
this was a suicide an accident or
potentially a homicide
from there more evidence will obviously
follow and i think the leads will have
to come from potential witnesses
tipsters and possibly even social media
that was posted all right certainly more
to come in this case thank you florina
and terry coming up on lawn crime daily
an ohio man stands trial for the murder
of his wife but was it murder or suicide
plus jury selection begins in florida
where a man stands trial for the
kidnapping and attempted murder of his
wife
[Music]
welcome back jury selection begins in
the florida trial of trevor summers a
man being tried for the 2017 attempted
murder and alleged kidnapping and sexual
assault of his estranged wife the case
goes back five years when after months
of conflict between summers and his wife
alisa mathewson the september before
summers have pleaded guilty to federal
conspiracy and wire fraud charges two
months later matheson filed for divorce
a judge barred the couple from seeing
each other but summers allegedly told
their then 14 year old daughter he
wanted to reconcile with mathewson and
needed some alone time with her
authorities say summers had planned a
murder-suicide and had convinced his
children to let him into matthewson's
house over the next three days summers
allegedly held matthewson captive in the
backseat of her suv
the defendant had opted to represent
himself on the trial but after several
attorneys were taken off his case but
right before jury selection began monday
that changed
mr summers what do you want to do um yes
john right i understand your position i
agree with you and um thank you
someone does
that's a start let's see where we go
i would um respectfully yield my uh
case to mr marchese excellent and um i
that's a wise decision mr marchese you
are the attorney on this case what would
you like to say boy
your honor welcome aboard yeah but uh
this is an absolute dilemma
he and i had numerous problems
throughout my representation i must have
felt three or four motions to
to
withdraw
uh mr summers must have found three or
four motions to kick me off those bushes
were all ruled they were all ruled on of
course and they would deny
a lot more to come be sure to follow the
trial on law and crime network for gavel
to gavel coverage lorena juries rarely
have an opportunity to hear from the
victim in a case like this what's the
impact of hearing from the wife
look it's going to be wonderful for the
defense attorney to have an opportunity
to cross-examine her and potentially
attack her credibility when i have the
opportunity to as a defense attorney
cross a victim
or alleged victim i like to try to
attack their credibility suggests that
perhaps this was consensual this was a
misunderstanding
obviously they're going through a
contentious divorce and she's got reason
here to be biased and to try to pin this
on him
terry as we saw mr summers has now
decided to have a lawyer he's not going
to represent himself anymore i assume
you think that was the right decision
it was absolutely the right decision
brian you know the old expression that
says one who represents himself has a
fool for a lawyer and so it's so many
problems that could come about if in
fact he did represent himself he would
not be aware of his available defenses
he wouldn't understand the court process
he'd have to draft his own emotions he
wouldn't have time for all that he'd
have to do his briefs and the worst part
of it is he would have to cross-examine
the witnesses and just imagine if he had
to cross-examine his wife the victim in
this case that would be awkward to say
the least i do think it's interesting
that the lawyer who is now going to
handle the case want it off and it's
also interesting that summers did not
want him as his own lawyer so i think
we're going to be seeing some
interesting dynamics in the courtroom
and i think it's going to be a very
difficult case for that lawyer because
he's going to have to listen to summer
who clearly wants to be the one who runs
the show so we'll see what happens but
it'll be interesting write a trial well
worth watching gay of the devil coverage
here on the long crime network when we
come back it's week two of ohio versus
matthew moore hear from the woman who
discovered the body of moore's wife
emily noble
and welcome back we head to ohio now
where one of the women involved in the
search for the victim in what
authorities say was the state suicide
death of emily noble now takes the stand
as her husband matthew moore stands
trial for her murder no bones reported
missing in late may of 2020 the day
after going out to celebrate her
birthday with her husband hundreds of
volunteers conducted search parties for
months but more reportedly never took
part
four months later a group of women found
noble's decomposing body in a wooded
area near their home kneeling beneath a
tree with a usb cord wrapped around her
neck officials had to use dental records
and dna to identify the body an autopsy
revealed the 52 year old suffered
multiple facial and neck fractures
authorities say her death was staged to
look like a suicide
moore was arrested and charged with her
murder the following june
one of the women who found noble took
the stand monday afternoon she explained
the moment they came across her body
so i stopped in the old clearing turned
to my right and then
that's when i saw emily
now when you say that's what that's when
you saw emily
what did you see i think that it was i
mean i didn't know it but my very first
reaction when i turned
i saw this figure sitting in the woods
and it my first immediate thought was
it's a little girl with her on her knees
with her back to me
facing away it was just immediate and i
said hi there
i startled because there was a person in
the woods with me
what'd you do next
then it was starting to think in this
like what i was start what i was seeing
my second thought was who would put a
life-sized doll in the middle of the
woods that just didn't make sense to me
and
the third thought i had was something's
not right did any of the three of you
get any closer to the body no
did you touch anything around the body
no
what did you do next
i think we collectively were
realizing what we were seeing
we said okay okay
we all thought it was her but we said we
got a call
i took my bag i had a string bag with me
and
opened it up to get a notebook out that
had detective grubs his phone number in
it but i've forgotten my notebook
i had my phone and my hand was shaking
the girl said it is an emergency if i
ever thought this was an emergency go
ahead and call 9-1-1
so i called 9-1-1
so florina she was very real and
emotional but what was the point of
calling her as a witness in that murder
case
um i think the only thing they wanted to
really get out of this is that the body
was not tampered with or touched because
remember the autopsy results are facial
fractures and neck fractures and that's
really important because the defense is
this is a suicide by a usb cord a usb
cord is not going to result in facial
fractures and a neck fracture and so the
only other possible defense or
explanation for those would be well
maybe whoever found her
stepped on her tampered with the body
did something to the body moved her and
caused those fractures and so while the
testimony itself doesn't seem
significant i believe the prosecution is
trying to close that door of explaining
away the fractures by having her be able
to say look we found her we called we
reported it we didn't touch the body we
didn't do anything in other words
there's no way they caused those
fractures
terry as we all know the prosecution has
the burden of proving the case beyond a
reasonable doubt how's the defense doing
raising doubts so far in the trial
oh i think that defense attorney has
done an excellent job so far starting
with the opening statement brian she
told that jury that she did not have to
present any evidence but guess what she
was going to anyway and one of the
witnesses that she
said she was going to call is an expert
who is testifying about the branch of
the tree and the fact that it could
withstand the weight of a body meaning
that it could have been a suicide and it
was not staged she also told that jury
that there was no physical evidence at
the scene and that's important if
there's no forensic physical evidence
then there's doubt there was no blood at
the scene and she explained that that
scene all of the scenes not just the
murder scene but where she was taken and
when the fact that there was no
witnesses so all of that i think could
easily raise some doubt she said that
the witness cooperated so we'll see what
happens here some very effective defense
work all right thank you florian
altschuler and terry austin thank you so
much thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you